a musicoterapia biomédica do som
o movimento o que repetiu duas vezes o
que geralmente quando eu explico que eu
trabalho com música terapia a reação é
música o que a musicoterapia a minha
formação em música
formei aqui neste palco recebi o meu
diploma de graduação
e quando eu decidi fazer música
perguntaram qual era a minha profissão
legal mas eu eu fiz música sim mas qual
a sua profissão né
não é música qual sua profissão itabom
professora de música melhorou para todo
mundo
no terceiro ano da faculdade
eu descobri algo chamado musicoterapia e
pesquisei muito sobre isso pesquisei
dois anos sobre a musicoterapia como
assim somar a música área da saúde como
pode e eu pensei em fazer o meu tcc
sobre a musicoterapia no entanto o meu
curso era de educação então não poderia
trabalhar com nada da área da saúde e
mantive aquele sonho eu quero fazer
música terapia me formei conseguir
depois logo depois o emprego e aí tive
oportunidade de sair e isto da
musicoterapia
eu pensei 'bom agora quando eu falar
musicoterapia as pessoas saberão qual é
a minha profissão né
aí eu falo é com a sua profissão o
musicoterapeuta aí veio música o que né
eu faço música com minha profissão eu
faço musicoterapia música o que então eu
vou tentar explicar um pouquinho agora
do que a musicoterapia
a musicoterapia iniciou durante a
segunda guerra mundial
os soldados feridos recebiam alguns
músicos que ficar
vão tocando e os profissionais da saúde
perceber uma certa evolução na
recuperação daqueles soldados
a partir daí começou a ser estudado a
musicoterapia hoje no brasil a
musicoterapia é reconhecida para você se
tornar um músico terapeuta você precisa
fazer uma graduação e musicoterapia ou
se especializar em musicoterapia caso
você seja da área da música ou da área
da saúde
o meu caso a musicoterapia começou de
uma forma muito forte
eu fiz a minha especialização no rio de
janeiro e o primeiro módulo
eu quando eu retornei do primeiro módulo
eu me deparei com algo muito grave aqui
em santarém
este esta cidade foi o cenário de toda a
história que eu vou contar com um amigo
chamado rafael sofreu um acidente
durante um acampamento desse dente
evoluiu com quadro de tetraplegia
ele tinha 1% de chance de andar a equipe
que trabalhava com ele a equipe de
fisioterapia
simplesmente acreditou que aquela lesão
não seria completa
aquela lesão era uma lesão incompleta e
você meu amigo eu acompanhei de perto me
envolvi muito porque esse caso é tão
importante porque ele era baterista um
dos melhores bateristas da cidade de uma
técnica muito forte e acima de tudo a
bateria é o instrumento que mais se
exige coordenação motora e aí perde-se o
movimento das mãos e das pernas como ele
vai continuar tocando
então eu acreditei na equipe de
fisioterapia e vamos confiar que a lesão
é incompleta
chegou um certo ponto em que eu tive que
iniciar é dá o start da musicoterapia e
eu não sabia quase nada
então eu sempre falo que essa história
minha experiência com o efeito da música
na reabilitação e não musicoterapia
porque ainda não era formada não tinhas
técnicas necessárias para falar que isso
era musicoterapia
então eu fui numa loja de instrumento e
fiquei pensando que eu posso comprar uma
primeira coisa preciso saber o que ele
precisa melhorar ea fisioterapeuta falou
olha a primeira coisa que nós precisamos
melhorar a respiração dele que está
irregular
então o que é feito quando a respiração
está irregular
você usa um balão ou uma luva de
procedimento para ficar secando e
enchendo ali vai ajudar e auxiliar a
respiração
eu cheguei numa loja de instrumento
musical e olhei aquela loja como se
fosse uma farmácia ou uma loja de
instrumentos que pudesse se passar por
uma loja de equipamentos médicos
eu achei um instrumento chamado escaleta
a escaleta é um instrumento um teclado
pequeno mas só sai o som se você só pra
você tem que sobrar corretamente para
você conseguir que o som seja emitido e
depois que rafael começou a estudar a
escaleta é na música a gente sempre fala
estudar um instrumento com duas semanas
depois voltei a respiração
aí nossa e isso dá certo
existe algo diferente na música que pode
trazer a reabilitação e pode trazer de
volta à saúde das pessoas
depois o próximo passo seria o movimento
das mãos
e aí eu pensei que você usa pra o
movimento das mãos
geralmente um altera todo mundo que faz
academia hoje já passou por uma sessão
de fisioterapia aquele peso que você faz
esse tipo de movimento então eu pensei
esse movimento também é feito no ganzá
aquele instrumento que geralmente você
vê no carnaval
então eu posso fazer esse movimento e
assim eu fui ganhando é mais formas de
poder auxiliar rafael
com isso hoje tentamos trazer pra ele
uma experiência com a música mais forte
eo rafael ele não consegue gritar ele
vai chamar uma pessoa do outro lado da
rua por exemplo ele não consegue
e aí uma vez nós tentamos reproduzir
aquele vídeo para nossa alegria
então a enfermeira que também era nossa
amiga cantou a mãe dele fez o papel da
mãe e ele era um rapaz do violão ele na
época não conseguia tocar o violão e eu
fiquei tocando por trás mas no vídeo e
na hora dele gritar para nossa alegria
como ele vai fazer isso ele não grita
mas vamos tentar ele de uma forma muito
lúdica mais nós sabia que a a meta era
outra né
e para nossa alegria o rafael cantor e
alto alto
a intensidade alta forte então aquilo
foi um momento bem interessante para a
gente entender puxa então as coisas
estão realmente dando certo
a música realmente pode trazer um
benefício
eu pensei eu não tenho mais o que fazer
passar um ano
eu montei uma bateria no quarto dele
muitos anos atrás eu tocava bateria como
eu sou mulher geralmente a bateria já
estava montada então eu não tinha esse
costume de montar bateria e passei quase
uma hora para montar uma bateria no
quarto do rafael
cansada foi para a cozinha tomar um suco
ea gente ouve as batidas calma ele ainda
não passa sozinho da cama para a cadeira
de rodas tem alguém no quarto com rafael
corremos no quarto ele estava lá na
bateria
passou sozinho da cama para a cadeira de
rodas pegou a cadeira de roda foi estava
tentando tocar então só o fato daquele
instrumento está ali
rafael simplesmente já se motivou e aí
foi confirmado não tinha lesão
incompleta ou e não tinha lesão completa
e se ele consegue fazer isso ele
consegue sentar não pode ser uma lesão
completa e ele é muito esperto
existe uma técnica da bateria chamada
pedal duplo então baterista ele tem um
pedal do lado direito um pedal do lado
esquerdo ele toca e faz fica bem rápido
o barulho do bumbum que aquele
instrumento que fica embaixo
ele tinha espasmos musculares e apenas
ficava sozinha tremendo
então ele conseguia fazer isso de uma
forma fenomenal
ele se aproveitava daquele momento e com
o braço e eu fazendo os ritmos assim é
todo mundo como ele está fazendo pedal
duplo com um pedal e ele sempre se
aproveitava muito daquilo pra pra tocar
imagina só um problema se tornando algo
interessante de se fazer algo que ele
tinha prazer em fazer
voltando à minha história eu estudei
nessa cidade
me formei neste palco depois dessa
situação
eu pensei por que não investir né a
musicoterapia realmente dá resultado
por que não investir fazer pesquisas
hoje eu sou uma pessoa apaixonada por
ciência
então eu fiz um projeto para identificar
como a musicoterapia poderia auxiliar e
pacientes pós operatório de punho e aí
muita gente fala que loucura é mais uma
vez quer fazer diferente né
mas eu acreditava que aquilo poderia
funcionar e eu fui aprovado no mestrado
e bioengenharia na linha de pesquisa
chamada novos processos terapêuticos
eu terminei o mestrado em um ano e três
meses e conseguiu patentear a idéia de
se mostrado anteriormente no processo
seletivo o coordenador falou
você não está apta a fazer o curso por
causa da sua formação você ea sua
graduação é educação
mas a gente vai confiar não nos
decepcione e eu consegui logo depois que
conseguiu foi convidado a voltar e fazer
o doutorado com bolsa
então há quatro anos atrás eu fui de vez
para são paulo e mora hoje em são josé
dos campos
finalizando o doutorado neste ano e hoje
é uma honra para mim poder voltar no
cenário onde tudo aconteceu no cenário
onde iniciou uma loucura para muitas
pessoas mas que o meu sonho era possível
na minha cabeça aquilo era possível e
hoje eu tento apresentar a musicoterapia
não para músico terapeutas
mas para em congressos médicos a
congressos de eletromiografia como que
se que coloca eletromiografia dentro da
musicoterapia e a gente tem conseguido
fazer isso tem conseguido os resultados
científicos para apresentar resultados
esses que têm sido eu tenho sido
convidada para palestrar em locais onde
eu jamais imaginei e uma certa vez eu
estava na escola politécnica da usp ea
coordenadora perguntou por que eu ainda
não tinha feito um vídeo pra falar sobre
isso
uma história tão boa mas que eu ouvi
tanto que não tinha nada a ver que eu
realmente não não empolguem dividir essa
história com as pessoas
então eu queria um canal e comecei a
compartilhar alguns vídeos contando essa
história explicando um pouquinho mais do
que a musicoterapia então o rafael se
ele não podia andar
rafael tinha uma lesão completa o que
aconteceu com rafael ele ainda mora em
santarém para minha grata surpresa eu
fui convidada a palestrar no texas em
santarém onde tudo aconteceu e eu posso
falar pra vocês
rafael dirige
ele anda bom quero que vocês vejam com
os próprios olhos
rafael
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e eu quero aproveitar este momento e
publicamente agradecer a rafael por ter
confiado na sua amiga por ter confiado
na música e o que a música poderia fazer
hoje eu sei que você tem investido muito
apesar de ter não está mais e
acompanhando mas eu sei o quanto você
tem crescido na música quanto você já
tem a sua banda
você tem o seu mini estúdio na sua casa
e o seu caso fez chegar onde eu estou
muito obrigada eu sou músico terapeuta
[Música]
meu nome é natália avelino com muito
orgulho eu sou musicoterapeuta e
acredito no poder da música
muito obrigado
[Música]